hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back in 1858 in uh
morphy's
blindfold simultaneous exhibition where
he faces eight uh
uh very very strong adversaries and uh
his opponent in this game is uh yabba
star he was the secretary of the
leamington chess club
and something very uh weird happened he
actually got this idea that he should
try and confuse
morphe by playing weird moves he thought
that okay maybe morphe was just
winning all of his games because he knew
all the variations by heart so maybe
he's just gonna you know play something
really weird and confuse morphy as he is
playing blindfold so here
uh really really wild game and also uh
maybe a reminder how not to play chess
and also
uh in the previous game i told you that
i would remake the video if you guys
sent me a photo of
john rhodes and a lot of you actually
sent me a photo of john rhodes but
some uh john rhodes that actually lives
today
uh and you know not for example in 1858
you send me like full
high resolution high quality color photo
uh that's not really what i asked for
but thank you for
for all the trouble you went through for
finding uh
such a gentleman in his photo and now
getting back to this game
uh morphe with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh we have h6
uh the beginning of the confusion begins
now and this is actually in theory
called
the tsar defense so h6 with d4
and now a5 playing on the other side of
the board now it's not
all that meaningless he does actually
have an idea of what he's doing here
uh but it's uh still you know to play
this against someone like morphy uh
we'll see what happens morphe continues
development bishop d6 and now
b6 now tsar wants to play bishop to a6
and trade off uh
his light square bishop for morphy's
light square bishop so morphy just
continues developing
uh knights to e2 he doesn't want to go
knight to f3 he wants to be able to push
the pawn to f4
uh whenever needed with e6 uh and
now morphy just castles and now bishop
to a6
so uh as uh uh luvental who was uh
annotating the games he said that
all of this is just uh played to try and
confuse the blindfold morphy
uh but morphe just continues developing
we have c4
knight to f6 now and uh e5 again pushing
the knight back
knight to h7 and now f4 and the blacks
pieces aren't
doing all that great uh actually none of
them are this knight is stuck here can't
really go anywhere
uh the bishop on a6 not not the greatest
of pieces uh but okay
the game is still young bishop to e7
preparing to castle king side and now
knight to g3 and now morphy has full
control of the f5 square
uh if black ever decides to castle king
side he can just bust open the position
with f5
with d5 by tsar and now uh queen the g4
i forgot to mention if there are any uh
of new of you who are new to the channel
uh since we don't have a photo of yabusa
i'm also wearing the hoodie to honor
uh the hoodie guy who always plays the
greatest of games
so queen to g4 going after that g7 pawn
and here
uh there really aren't all the great uh
many moves here g6 you could try and
play something like this
but then even ideas like bishop captures
and g6 come to mind so here
uh tsar just castled but now uh morphe
goes for it
knight the h5 and now uh morphe is
already threatening checkmate so you
have to defend it
uh we have g5 and now f captures on g5
h captures on g5 and now as low intel
mentioned
while annotating the game black has
indeed placed himself in a deplorable
condition in
vainly attempting to puzzle his
antagonist and here
morphy's completely winning and he
actually has a forced
checkmate in eight moves uh morphe
played something else he actually played
a mate in nine
uh but if you feel like it you know you
are comfortable in your own home
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to find uh a forced
mate in eight sequence for morphe uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on beating morphe
to the punch as you've
uh checked made it start a move before
morphe and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's uh
not bishop captures an h7 that's what
morphy played
it's actually knight to f6 check and now
the point is that the bishop and queen
no longer guard the g5 pawn
if black doesn't react to this you can
just pick up the pawn and that's it
uh not much for black to do there or
even just queen to h5
if for example king to ha display the
point is you have to capture the knight
and after bishop captures an f6 now
queen to h5
and this is the whole point now you've
blocked the f5 pawn the f5 phone cannot
be played
this is the thread of checkmate and the
knight has nowhere to go
all of the squares are blocked so here
you have to play rook 8 to make some
room for the king but now comes
check uh queen captures an h7 king of f8
and rook captures an f6 and that's it
this is the threat of checkmate after
you defend it
now comes bishop to g5 and here it's
just game over
uh whatever you do uh it's uh it's just
gonna go to queen to h8 king here
and then the rook will move delivering
check doesn't matter what
uh black plays because there are no good
moves here if rook c8 we're just going
to show it as it is beautiful uh
queen to h8 check king to e7 and now the
amazing rook
captures an e6 a double check forcing
black to capture the rook as the queen
covers the entire back rank
between king captures and now queen to
f6 is checkmate so congratulations to
everyone who found this
but to anyone who played morphe's move
that's also perfectly fine as
you know morphe was playing blindfold so
we can uh excuse him for not
going for the absolute quickest way of
checkmating his opponent
so bishop captures an h7 was played and
now of course if you capture
then again we have this knight to f6
check bishop captures in queen h5
check uh king to g8 and now rook
captures on f6
uh it's not much better not not much for
for uh
black to to to accomplish here even just
the rook here to here will be checkmate
and even if you give up the queen it's
still not enough you can make room for
let's say the king you move but just
queen h6 and that's it uh black is
getting checkmated
so here after murphy's bishop captures
an h7 we have king the h8
uh not capturing but still knight f6 the
thread is still queen h5 and everything
is the same
d captures on c5 uh there is no good
move here for black
and now bishop back to c2 first clearing
uh the head the way for the for the
white queen but this
actually allows black uh at least a
little bit of hope because he can
prolong the game now
uh morphy probably missed this playing
blindfold and it doesn't really help
black but it does prolong the game
uh queen captures on d4 with check
a temporary queen sacrifice because he
will win it back queen captures on d4
and now bishop to c5 uh pins the queen
and now morphy has to give back the
queen so queen captures in c5
b captures and now uh bishop captures on
g5 so black survived a little bit longer
but it's not enough morphy's position is
much better and also
he's up much much more material
so here knight to c6 and now just rook
to f3 here it's actually a force check
made in seven and morphe instantly finds
it
uh even playing blindfold uh rook to f3
uh and after king to g7 not allowing
rook to h3 to come with check
feel free to pause the video for the
last time and try to find the absolute
quickest way to win it's actually a
force made in six
so while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations as this is not
an easy one to find
and uh for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show that's uh
bishop to h6 with check uh knight the e8
check also works knights the h5 check
also works
but this is the quickest and this is in
fact what morphe played so it's a
temporary bishop sacrifice
if you decline the sacrifice it's even
faster just rook h3
and next the bishop to f8 is checkmate
even if you move the rogue bishop to f8
it is still checkmate
that's why it's so it's so uh nice so
after bishop to h6 check
uh king captures and now comes rook the
h3 check
uh again doesn't matter where you go if
king eg7 then rook to h7 is checkmate so
you have to go down the board
uh king the g5 and now comes rook to h5
with check king to f4 and now uh morphy
finishes the game in a beautiful fashion
king to f2
uh he gains the opposition takes away
the e3 square from the black king and
it's
checkmate on the next move and he was in
fact in this position uh that his
opponent
yabba start resigned to the game and as
you can see he wasn't able to confuse
morphy even a little bit
uh let alone embarrass him uh but uh
yeah
here it's mate on the next move of
course g3 checkmates uh the black king
or if you really want to be that person
yes rook the g8 prolongs the game then
we can sacrifice the rook and the sh
captures on g3 it's only now checkmate
uh but of course uh yabistar was not
that person he resigned here and again
a wonderful victory for morphy uh in
this blindfold simultaneous exhibition
and i don't think after this game anyone
uh
ever tried to confuse morphy uh in a
in any contest let alone let alone a
blindfold one
uh so yeah uh once again a wonderful
victory for morphe i hope you guys
enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh andrew
nelson uh ever david beltran pinto
abu dhendra shukla pete macdonald and
stephen davies for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check uh two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day